when we first started shooting the movie
we did this video that went out where I
was we were on in Abu Dhabi and I was
standing there and there was a creature
in the in the scene and some people
there it is um and and some people
working oh great you know you made
creatures and other people thought oh
it's a CG thing and we wanted to show
you it wasn't CG and this is just one of
many character so we actually brought
this character we called Bobby Joe as a
nickname so let's should we bring Bobby
two out yeah I think so absolutely let's
see all right everyone crossed their
fingers cross your fingers here we go
alright so this character here he comes
amazing let's see no I don't want to
scare 2 is built by Neil Scanlon and the
creature Department let's see this word
so okay yeah Neil Neil Scanlon these
guys have done an unbelievable job as
you can see we're gonna hope that he
does not fall off the stage here so I'm
just coming I'm keeping an eye on him
and I will I will give my life to save
him eat baba Joe's a little slow so
we're just gonna give a little room here
so how's it going good to see you hi how
are you hello how are you doing don't
eat that don't eat that so uh this is
one of hundreds of creatures that they
built for this this film and what's
amazing is is seeing the the people who
operate these things and the real
benefit of having creatures like this
you can see that character right there
you know there are there are five people
who are operating that that creature and
a lot of these creatures are even our
background creatures they're not even
the main event but what's so cool about
them is it gives the actors who are in
scenes things to actually deal with
interact with play with respond to uh it
also helps even things like light the
way light reflects on the set and on the
character so it's a big deal all these
these creatures you're seeing oh and
it's amazing to because even though
we're not we decided not to use CG the
the robotic technology is really
advanced as you can see well yeah I mean
and especially he's gonna walk all the
way back across this won't fall this
time uh this is work gets ugly but this
is not easy for anyone for anyone who
grew up with the original Star Wars and
it was it was part of the the charm of
the movie was being able to see these
characters look as though they were had
come to life and I think CG certainly
has its place but seeing a practical
effect I mean even seeing that seeing
him wiggle his nose in that way it does
something emotionally that reminds us of
the first time we ends all star wars and
the friend and the little friends along
the side oh oh here s your dog all right
excellent and would you you said this
was an eel Scanlon yeah yeah Neil scelan
and his team the most amazing creature
shop I'm fine and there he goes all
right and there we go huge and for Bobbi
Jo
you